this is a VW repair shop somewhere in
Germany customers want to know whether
their cars are affected by the emissions
scandal some of them are really upset
when year is up god forbid my car has
that dodgy software in it I'll soon it's
really disgraceful lately air pollution
is still a problem here German
automakers are required by law to comply
with rigorous pollution control
standards but if they don't most people
don't seem to notice some
environmentalists say government
regulators need to make it tougher for
automakers to get their certification
this is agent Lee lunafly sob I dish
must even lot of it is just red-tape
siege are the companies have to fill out
all these forms on safety and
environmental regulations they've got to
be able to prove what they say and
provide independent verification [ __ ]
Papio and they hand over all this
paperwork and then get their
certification on typical money to lessen
the tooth is an independent German
organization that tests product safety
its process for testing cars is thorough
its emissions tests aim to recreate a
range of actual driving conditions the
automaker's optimize their engines to
pass these tests and if the emissions
results look good on paper the two have
passes that on to the government
authorities the workers at this repair
shop aren't terribly surprised about the
VW scandal one mechanic says car makers
have been fudging the figures for years
this club kinda runs idea no one
believes those numbers and they haven't
for years we all know that the test
results have nothing to do with actual
driving conditions in a hollow metal
Alison leave us a tune heart this seems
to be common knowledge shut the Federal
Bureau of Motor Vehicles look into this
and revise the tests
the bureau's headquarters are located in
the northern city of Flensburg the
bureau told us that spot checks on
emissions are not provided for under
current legislation the
environmentalists disagree with the
bureau's policy they say that
authorities could carry out these tests
if they wanted to the sky blue Nizam
today the Bureau is correct the tests
are done only at service facilities
that's the way they do it in the u.s. to
but the Bureau is also required to make
sure that these tests are carried out
correctly op diesel sooo close off the
hauler collect kafan but so are German
cars pumping out more pollution than the
law allows VW has admitted it cheated on
emissions tests but environmentalists
claim other automakers also fiddle their
emissions figures Alec was entitled o
hasta la a new car is made by the big
German companies exceed the standard
emissions limit by an average of seven
hundred percent and the Alpha of those
companies include BMW Daimler opal Ford
VW and audi fort forks wagon OD we've
published a report that outlines this
situation z will not send or in some
cases the cars exceed the limit by two
thousand percent you bots White House
important right now of course the focus
is on foulkes wagon the company will
have to refit all those cars that have
been using dodgy software what looks
like we're gonna be busy yeah the
emissions scandal has been a disaster
for VW it will likely be good news for
repair shops